I said did you ever have the Imposter
syndrome you know when you were at UC
Berkeley working for these famous Nobel
Laureate you know physicists did you
ever feel like you weren't good enough
he goes what do you mean did I
I still feel the Imposter syndrome I was
like what are you talking about he said
I feel it worse than ever
and I said you gotta explain what are
you talking about he said when you win
the Nobel Prize
you go to Stockholm you meet the king
you bend down and he puts this golden
gilded engraved image of Alfred Nobel in
your neck and you get a check for some
fraction or a hundred percent of a
million dollar uh payout and uh and you
get this portrait this really beautiful
portrait I tried to reproduce the
portraits with a really nice work of an
artist in this book I think he did a
wonderful job and um and and and then
you have to sign this Ledger that says
yes I receive my Nobel Prize and all the
accoutrements and Delicacies they're in
and uh and he said when I did that I'm a
very curious person I couldn't resist
who signed it before me so he turned
back the pages he saw Richard Feynman
Marie Curie and he saw Albert Einstein
and he said Dave and the hair still
stands up he said I'm not worthy I am
not Einstein I am not good enough to be
there and it made me feel completely
inadequate completely un up to the tap
not up to the task and now I'm in the
same league as Einstein I do not deserve
it and I said thinking quickly I said
Barry guess what
you know also had the Imposter syndrome
Albert Einstein because Albert Einstein
was in awe and holy inadequate before
Isaac Newton
speaking of Woody Allen and sleeper do
we still not have the cryo sleep things
I mean they were an Interstellar too
they were in all the alien movies do
those things exist where are we at with
those things I don't know every time I
go down to my biology lab uh colleagues
they're always a sleeper
sucking frogs and you know if you had
access to those many chemicals and drugs
Dave what would you be doing come on put
yourself in a bag in some hot water
usually and then and then they get yeah
it was in the Martian too with uh one of
those brownies that you still have left
over from 1997. exactly I wish I had
those John Mather the collaborator
yeah John is an incredible guy who also
was kind of a wonderkind and and did a
tremendous amount of work he is the
stereotypical although he's not a
professor he's a stereotypical you know
Professor just super uh super smart can
answer and knows everything about about
you know the the field and has
contributed to many many great uh great
discoveries and is about to be the chief
you know scientist behind this new Space
Telescope that's going to be launched in
December hopefully after a 20-year delay
it's one of the most expensive projects
NASA's ever done and it's a successor to
the Hubble Space Telescope which has
revealed more wonders and Mysteries of
the cosmos than any other project
um and so he uh he discovered not
serendipitously so he's an example of a
different type of scientific discovery
which is that you make an extremely
precise measurement of a known quantity
something that we knew existed this
microwave background radiation that I
study comes in all directions originally
discovered in New Jersey and uh but he
made the most Exquisite measurement ever
that put the nail in the coffin of any
other Alternatives that could plausibly
be said to be responsible for the
appearance of our universe namely there
are people that believed up until then
in the early 90s that the Universe could
have existed forever in what's called a
steady state and the measurements that
he did for technical reasons really
destroyed all hope for those who
believed in an alternative to what we
now call The Big Bang
initiation of the universe so he is uh
you know this really quintessential
workman-like studious bookish very very
bright very very diligent he just keeps
going and again these guys could all
retire and be you know super famous and
do whatever they want to do and yet he's
working super hard on this on this next
Great Space Telescope the the dividends
of which may not come for decades or
more How does it go for a guy like that
when he sort of puts that final nail as
you put it and and it sort of blows up
what may in his field think about
something I suspect there's probably a
lot of resentment there's probably a lot
of denial but slowly kind of people come
along usually
yeah well that's what's so interesting
in that chapter he talks about the
importance of listening to your critics
but not too much
and I kind of summarized this as a trait
um you know in in my students I say you
have to be humble you have to nobody
likes someone who's not humble and we'll
talk about you know imposter syndrome
and stuff in a little bit I'm sure but
you need humility but you need Swagger
too you need the Swagger to know that
you're doing a good job that you are
competent you can't just go oh timid I'm
humble yeah I can't do anything
um and in his case there were these
really vociferous calls that you know
that the Big Bang is wrong and it's
actually just a product of you know of
of religious scientists if you can
believe such a thing and and uh this
this impulse that human beings have to
believe in Genesis 1 1 et cetera Etc and
in the end he said you can listen to
those people you can respect their
scientific contributions but you
shouldn't listen so much that you uh
really undermine your own confidence so
it's listening to your critics not
necessarily letting their comments go to
your to your heart but um but but maybe
ingesting them into your mind processing
them analytically and saying is there a
way and I translated this and we talked
about this before you know steel Can you
steal man your critic and can you build
up his or her counter argument to your
pet Theory or pet experiment and if you
can't it's not a guarantee that you're
wrong you may be right and they may be
just a blundering idiot who just
believes in some stupid model but in the
case where you can actually reproduce
their arguments it makes your case that
much more strong and I think that's a
trait I want to imbue and you know other
people to to take to heart no matter
what their field and I think he
exemplifies that I suspect that goes far
better in the Laboratories that you
people work in rather than the Twitter
scape I'm pretty well yeah pretty sure I
don't need to run an experiment on that
my life has been a living experiment of
that we've got one more and then if you
don't mind I'm gonna throw in my own
scientist I have not planned anything in
advance with you but I'm going to throw
in someone that has influenced me
tremendously but the last one number
nine Barry barish uh the avuncular
Avatar yeah so Barry kind of represents
the physicist that I want to be and that
and that the Avatar aspect of that and
avuncular because he is just such a a
warm gracious uh individual so Barry
really in some ways is responsible for
this book's existence because it was
during the recording of this episode
with him on my podcast into the
impossible uh that he said something
that was kind of interesting and
provocative to me and then I went
further learning the rubinik skills that
I've learned from you
um and I went deeper and what are you
talking about he said to me Dave and it
blew me away I said when you were young
were you like this stereotypical
brilliant kid in math and saying he's
like no I was never you know I was good
I was hard worker I was smart but you
know he grew up in Oklahoma and uh and
then later moved to LA and and so forth
and then he was just like persistent and
he always wanted to do a certain type of
work called particle physics and um you
know but he was never under this
impression that he was you know great I
said did you ever have the Imposter
syndrome you know when you were at UC
Berkeley working for these famous Nobel
Laureate you know physicists did you
ever feel like you weren't good enough
he goes what do you mean did I
I still feel the Imposter syndrome I was
like what are you talking about he said
I feel it worse than ever
and I said you gotta explain what are
you talking about he said when you win
the Nobel Prize
you go to Stockholm you meet the king
you bend down and he puts this golden
gilded engraved image of Alfred Nobel in
your neck and you get a check for some
fraction or a hundred percent of a
million dollar uh payout and uh and you
get this portrait this really beautiful
porch I tried to reproduce the portraits
with a really nice work of an artist in
this book I think he did a wonderful job
and um and and and then you have to sign
this Ledger that says yes I receive my
Nobel Prize and all the accoutrements
and Delicacies they're in and uh and he
said when I did that I'm a very curious
person I couldn't resist who signed it
before me so he turned back the pages he
saw Richard Feynman Marie Curie and he
saw Albert Einstein and he said Dave and
the hair still stands up he said I'm not
worthy I am not Einstein I am not good
enough to be there and it made me feel
completely inadequate completely un up
to the tat not up to the task and now
I'm in the same league as Einstein I do
not deserve it
and I said thinking quickly I said Barry
guess what
you know who also had the Imposter
syndrome Albert Einstein because Albert
Einstein was in awe and holy inadequate
before Isaac Newton
and he felt Isaac Newton Dave can you
imagine if Einstein were tweeting today
he said the following he said Isaac
Newton revolutionized not only science
but Western culture Western Civilization
he canceled immediately he said Newton
had more influence on civilization not
just science than any human before or
since meaning including Albert Einstein
who was writing this about noon and I
said but wait Barry it doesn't stop
there
Isaac Newton had the severe case of the
Imposter syndrome he said what do you
mean I said he felt completely
inadequate before his Idol not a
scientist but uh Jesus Christ in fact
Newton said his highest accomplishment
in life is that he died a virgin like
Jesus Christ and he wanted to emulate
Christ in every way so I think it's very
fascinating and guess what you know I
don't know maybe Jesus didn't have
enough maybe Jesus didn't feel the
imposters in but he was pretty humble
and I think he was a pretty brilliant
human being so um or God depending on on
your perspective right so uh I think we
all can learn this lesson because if you
think that you're the greatest person
and you're of these great contributions
and you have like I won the Nobel Prize
like there are guys I'm not gonna say
who but there are people in the book who
said I don't have the Imposter syndrome
I deserve this freaking thing you know
like Flavor Flav with a huge Medallion
around his neck
um but they they feel like the desert
but not all of them and I think that
it's it was a dichotomy that I wasn't
suspecting it was an economy that you
need to have like I said humility and
Swagger but um but you need to be very
careful about it because the Imposter
syndrome is born out of insecurity and
people that are arrogant and and
unpleasant they're also insecure right
the old joke and you know this from your
dog you know the smallest dog barks the
loudest right that's that's the thing
right you talk to Jocko on your podcast
Jocko's not like oh I'm going to kick
her you know he's just like whatever man
like I'll run away like I'll put on my
my running shoes and get out of there so
I think that's really interesting
because it's very rare that the opposite
two different traits in diametric
opposition come from the same Source
insecurity is responsible for imposter
syndrome and for the uh for the
arrogance that that many non-humble
people feel so I felt it was important
to distill this and who better to learn
it from than someone who's achieved and
gotten into the Promised Land
of my field is the Nobel Prize there's
no higher thing in all of science maybe
even all of culture civilization and
Society than the Nobel Prize and so I
felt these people in particular Barry
and I was so honored that he wrote the
forward to the book
um uh as well that was really a great
honor that I do not feel worthy of if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about Academia
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our Academia playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell